la série sur la démocratie est finie
c'est un petit peu triste mais c'est
aussi une super nouvelle puisque ça va
nous permettre d'aborder un nouveau
thème sur scène ce forum alors pour tout
vous dire il ya un thème que j'ai
vraiment vraiment vraiment vraiment
envie d'aborder mais pour des raisons
secrètes obscur et peut-être même
hérétiques
je préfère laisser ça pour plus tard en
attendant d'aborder mon thème secret je
vous propose d'aborder un thème que vous
allez élire
sauf que contrairement à monsieur fille
je me refuse à vous laisser l'embarras
de quatre choix seulement je vous
propose en fait une collection de neuf
options qui sont toutes très proches des
mathématiques et de l'informatique
le lien pour voter et dans la
description et bien entendu on va
utiliser un scrutin de condorcet
randomisés qui a été implémentée par
pierre une à vaux sur le site votation
point ovh et oui vous pouvez maintenant
organiser vos propres scrutin de
condorcet randomisés ont assité à régis
verser présentant les candidats à
l'élection
choix numéro un les nombres en tout
genre dans cette option je vous propose
l'étude dénombre bizarroïde mercuria les
nombres entiers naturels qu'on connaît
si bien et notamment ses mystérieux
nombres premiers
mais il ya aussi les nombres réels et
imaginaires hyper réel complexe hyper
complexe et même des nombreux sur réel
sans parler des nombres modulaire des
nombreux pays indiquent des nombres de
l'informatique les flottes et les
doubles et peut-être aussi si on attend
on parlera de généralisation des nombres
savoir des nombres qui ne communiquent
pas choix numéro 2 l'algèbre et les
structures dans cette option sera amené
à parler du mystérieux evariste galois
et de sa si merveilleuse théorie on
parlera aussi de l'étude généralisée et
abstraite des structures que ce soit les
mots no id les groupes les anneaux et
les corps et on découvrira que ces
structures abstraite se retrouve en fait
au coeur de la mécanique quantique
notamment les fameux groupe de lee choix
numéro trois les espaces de grande
dimension avec l'option 3 on part
explorer ces espaces de grandes
dimensions ces espaces dimensions 4 5 ou
même haine ou même un fini en
particulier je vous propose de voir
comment ces étranges espace abstrait
permettent de modéliser un nombre
faramineux de problèmes de ce qu'est une
image à comment représenter les
caractéristiques abstraite d'un film en
passant par le sens des mots et par les
états quantiques de l'univers choix
numéro 4 l'intelligence artificielle et
le machine
à un sujet qui ne nécessite sans doute
pas trop d'introduction aujourd'hui
toutes les entreprises du numérique sont
dans une course effrénée à la recherche
d'une intelligence artificielle mais
qu'est ce que l'intelligence
artificielle
je vous propose d'en étudier quelques
principes fondateurs et de voir qu'en
fait le fonctionnement d'un intelligence
artificielle n'est pas si différent de
la manière dont l'intelligence humaine
fonctionne à supposer que l'intelligence
humaine fonctionne on parlera de plein
de bisous wars comme le pit data ou le
type learning et on essaiera de faire le
tri entre le brigitte et ce qui a de
bonnes chances d'être le next pic choix
numéro 5 cliptographie et communication
j'avais dit à parler un peu de
cryptographie avec razvan barbulescu
mais il ya tellement plus la dir
j'aimerais prendre plus le temps pour
expliquer les exploits de turing pour
déchiffrer la machine enigma et sauver
les alliés d'une famille certaine on
verra aussi comment cette cryptographie
c'est mathématisée notamment grâce aux
travaux fondateurs de claude shannon en
théorie de l'information et à ceux de
nage caudle cook ou encore cars au point
qu'aujourd'hui on est à peu près sûr de
ne pas savoir grand chose
quant à la sécurité de la cryptographie
moderne
choix numéro 6 le hasard et les lois des
probabilités avec l'option 6 on verra
que notre intuition du hasard c'est un
petit peu de la merde et qu'il nous faut
absolument des outils rigoureux pour
étudier la nature du hasard mais surtout
on verra qu'il ya quelque chose
d'absolument fascinant à découvrir que
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
naïvement le hasard ne laisse en fait
pas beaucoup de place au hasard parce
que je veux dire par là c'est que le
vrai hasard possède d'étonnantes
régularité qui rendent beaucoup de ses
propriétés étonnamment prévisible
choix numéro 7 i'll go rythme et théorie
du calcul alors aujourd'hui les
algorithmes on en entend beaucoup parler
notamment parce qu'on est entouré
d'ordinateurs pourtant quand elle
khwarizmi invente à l'algorithmique au
9e siècle
bayh avait pas d'ordinateur en fait
l'étude des algorithmes c'est quelque
chose d'incroyablement plus profond que
celle de windows linux ou autre
excellent en fait pour les
mathématiciens church et turing notre
univers entier serait gouverné par un
algorithme et ça ça a des conséquences
assez
curieuse en particulier l'algorithmique
a bouleversé ma façon de voir le monde
et les mathématiques
choix numéro huit systèmes dynamiques et
chaos
avec cette option on verra que le temps
rend les choses souvent bien compliqué
on verra notamment en quoi la croissance
exponentielle dépasse complètement notre
entendement
pourquoi mélanger les cartes henry folle
folle c'est vraiment beaucoup mieux mais
aussi ce que signifie vraiment le chaos
et comment il peut émerger de situations
étonnamment simple en donnant lieu au
passage à des formes géométriques
incroyable comme l'ensemble de mangold
route
choix numéro 9 les pièges statistiques
du pic data les statistiques nous
entoure de plus en plus et on nous les
rabâche à coups d'arguments plein
d'hooliganisme est comme ça ressemble à
des mains à temps a tendance à y croire
pourtant les statistiques sont en fait
plein de pièges et de paradoxe apparent
avec cette option
on verra que statistiques m mentir et
adore nous induire en erreur
et bien sûr on cherchera à s'armer pour
mieux les affronter a que de beaux
sujets je pense qu on a des belles
années à venir sur scène sora en fait
j'ai bien fait gaffe à choisir des
sujets qui m'enthousiasme tous les uns
autant que les autres si bien que je
suis vraiment un différend entre tous
ces neuf sujets j'espère que ce n'est
pas votre cas et que vous allez prendre
le temps de m'aider à choisir
d'ailleurs sachez que le vote déjà
commencé et on peut d'ailleurs voir les
résultats intermédiaires après 200 votes
c'est cela en ce moment c'est
l'intelligence artificielle gagne mais
avec cette vidéo youtube je sens que il
va avoir beaucoup plus de votes et que
le classement temporaire risque d'être
bouleversée en tout cas je suis bien
curieux de voir où est ce que tout ça va
nous mener
sachez que le vote se termine ce
dimanche pas d'ici là dites moi ce que
vous voulez voir